[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui aux graves
conséquences des essais nucléaires
français en polynésie et pour cela j'ai
le plaisir de m'entretenir avec mike
brodeur sonne député de la polynésie
française du parti indépendantiste
tavini huiraatira y bonjour monsieur
brun personne merci nous accorder cet
entretien alors je parlais de ses graves
conséquences des essais nucléaires
français dans le pacifique qui ont été
menées entre 1966 et 1996 des graves
conséquences de ses 196 essai c'est
presque un euphémisme combien de
personnes sont touchées et de quelle
manière
alors vous savez ces essais ils ont
d'abord été menés en aérien
ça concerne 46 essais c'est près de 800
fois hiroshima et ensuite il ya eu les
essais dans le souterrain et on peut
dire que les essais aériens à tout le
moins on toucher l'intégralité de la
population polynésienne qui étaient
présentes à ce moment là c'est à dire
environ cent vingt mille personnes
cent vingt mille personnes tirent eux
s'ils ont eu de quel type de maladie
ensuite alors vous avez toute une série
de pathologies de type cancéreuse qui
ensuite se sont développés dont on a vu
les chiffres augmenter dès 1974 donc
quelques années après les premiers
essais on a vu également d un taux de
mortalité infantile dans les atolls
environnants directement vos nouveaux ou
dans l'archipel des gambier on a vu des
malformations sur des nouveau nés
donc tout un ensemble de pathologies
qui sont lourdes et qui sont
invalidantes sur des morts des
pathologies très grave est encore plus
choquant une enquête qui a été publié en
mars dans mars dernier par les
collectifs d'investigation disclose en
partenariat avec l'université de
princeton a montré que des militaires
français dans certains essaient savait
qu'il pouvait y avoir des conséquences
très graves sur la population et
pourtant ils ont mené les essais donc il
y aurait un mensonge d'état c'est aussi
votre conviction c'est plus une
conviction c'est une certitude
vous savez au départ des essais on va
dire chez nous le cep le centre
d'expérimentation du pacifique
s'installe en 1963 et en et en 1961 vous
avez l'armée américaine qui a fini ses
propres essais dans le nevada notamment
qui transmet à son homologue français un
rapport très documenté sur les
conséquences prévisibles d'essais
nucléaires aériens et dans ce rapport il
y a en gros toutes les pathologies qu'on
découvre à partir de 1974
ils sont aujourd'hui inscrites dans la
loi morin il y a il y à toutes ces
informations
ce rapport à les traduit dès 1962 et
d'encore 1963 quand le ceb démarre c'est
en toute connaissance de cause que
l'état français décide de poursuivre
malgré tous ces essais de les poursuivre
et en plus comme on a vu dans les
révélations disclose avec des vents
contraires ils ont tout de même mené les
opérations alors que les vents
contraires faisait qu'il y avait des
retombées radioactives sur certaines
îles habitées
oui vous savez on a des témoignages
glaçant de d'anciens militaires qui à un
moment donné demandent à leurs états
majors mais est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
doit tout de même mené cet essai le vent
vient de tourner et
l'umq l'état major la réponse oui il
faut absolument continuer parce que
sinon on à l'ars meurent et les
populations et ça mettrait en danger la
suite des essais vous avez un de ces
essais le plein d'idées le premier en
fait vous avez donc peu d des erreurs de
prévision qui vont s'avérer
catastrophique pour les populations
polynésiennes
alors justement ces révélations très
choquant de l'enquète de disques lozeau
conduit à l'organisation d'une table
ronde le 1er et 2 juillet souhaité par
emmanuel macron pour améliorer les
réparations au peuple polynésien et vous
l'avez boycotter pourquoi bien parce que
d'une part c'est une moi j'ai considéré
dès le départ que c'était ce n'était pas
une démarche sincère
vous savez les revendications des
polynésiens par rapport aux essais
nucléaires sont connus depuis 30 ans
maintenant c'est toujours les mêmes
revendications qui reviennent sur la
prise en charge des victimes indirectes
sur l'étude des malades des transmission
générationnelle sur l'environnement
puisque aujourd'hui le dispositif morin
ne comprends absolument aucun article
sur la dépollution et d'autres sujets
dans tous ces sujets sont sur la table
et connus de l'état depuis 30 ans et il
faut simplement c'est ce buzz
international créé par an que l'étude
disclose qui finalement est reprise au
vol par le président vaincrons et qui
ont fait une opération comme à dix mois
des élections présidentielles donc moi
je suis député et je suis là pour faire
un travail de fond j'ai travaillé
pendant deux ans pour une proposition de
loi qui a été balayé dans le vert demain
quelques semaines avant cette table
ronde donc ici n'y avait aucune logique
à participer à cette mascarade et je
voudrais juste rajouter que les
conclusions
cette table ronde les décisions qui ont
été annoncées par l'état
finalement était scripté à l'avance la
délégation polynésienne seraient venus
ou ne serais pas venu ça n'aurait
absolument rien changé à ce qui a été
annoncé par le président vaincrons on
reparlera de ces mesures tout à l'heure
en tout cas sur ce qui s'est dit à la
ministre de
mémoire et des anciens combattants
geneviève darrieussecq à elle dit que la
france n'avait pas commis de mensonges
d'état qu'est ce qu'on peut répondre à
cela
ce que vous avez les éléments mais c'est
totalement totalement surréaliste et
pathétique d'antan le ca pour moi ce
n'est pas un ministre de la mémoire avec
les ministres de l'amnésie vous savez le
président lui-même lors de la table
ronde parce que je n'y étais pas mais
j'ai des amis qui était le président
lui-même a reconnu qu'il y avait eu ce
mensonge d'état
donc ensuite lors de la conférence de
presse venir nous dire qu'il n'ya pas eu
de mensonges d'état c'est proprement
scandaleux elle devrait elle devrait
démissionner et pourquoi cette
difficulté à demander pardon parce qu'il
y aura de toute manière des indemnités
au fil du temps je pense que c'est une
c'est une posture de l'état vous savez
ces essais c'est finalement un des
derniers actes coloniaux qui ont eu lieu
en polynésie ils ont été imposées aux
polynésiens ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
nous qui avons demandé à ce que les
essais nucléaires se fasse chez nous
c'est de gaulle à l'époque donc qui pour
mettre en place la politique de
dissuasion nucléaire à imposer ses
essais puisque il ne pouvait plus tenir
en algérie qui allait devenir
indépendante et la france a beaucoup de
mal à fin de l'état français en tout cas
a beaucoup de mal à gérer son son passé
et son présent coloniale est d'admettre
qu'il ya eu ce mensonge d'état
c'est quelque chose d'insupportable on
va dire pour pour l'état je pense que il
faut bien différencier dans ce dossier
comme dans d'autres dossiers
le peuple français la nation française
et l'état
moi je n'ai aucun souci avec le peuple
français la nation française est une
grande nation mais l'état c'est un
appareil dogmatique c'est un appareil
qui a beaucoup de mal à
finalement être honnête avec les
français avec les polynésiens avec
l'humain françois hollande avait fait un
premier pas mais c'était un tout petit
pas en réalité où il françois hollande
lors de sa venue en polynésie avait
déclaré qu'il y avait bien eu des
conséquences graves sur la santé des
polynésiens et sur l'environnement
maintenant il avait fait des promesses à
l'époque lui aussi qui n'ont pas été
tenues
le président macron doit venir en
polynésie du 25 au 27 juillet prochain
il va de nouveau faire des promesses
certainement pour on va dire s'attirer
les voix peut-être des polynésiens pour
les présidentielles mais vous savez je
crois qu'aujourd'hui plus personne n'est
dupe on va parler de ces essais comme on
disait tout à l'heure
certains vent ont provoqué des retombées
radioactives sur des îles avec de graves
conséquences
autre conséquence également des pluies
radioactives sur une île habitée
thurillet en 1971 et cela a contaminé
les eaux les français l'ont su ils sont
venus faire des relevés mais la
population n'a pas été informé en
réalité les polynésiens n'ont pas eu
d'informations de manière générale c'est
le prédicat même qui a prévalu au choix
de la polynésie par l'armée française
c'est que cette population là en
particulier ne connaissez absolument
rien du nucléaire donc il a été très
facile pour l'état pendant des années de
nous vendre la thèse d essai prend
vous savez il n'ya pas que les
polynésiens qui ont été victimes de ce
mensonge d'état il y à tous les
métropolitains qui ont jeunes engagés
qui sont venus travailler au centre
d'expérimentation du pacifique qui eux
non plus ne savais absolument rien de la
dangereuse la dangerosité réelle de ces
essais et c'est moi je les ai rencontrés
je les rencontre régulièrement
dernièrement j'étais à l'arc de triomphe
avec la veine l'association des vétérans
des essais nucléaires
et quand ces vétérans vous dise certes
pour certains en tout cas qu'ils ont
démissionné le jour où ils ont su que
l'état menthe et que l'armée mentez et
qu'on leur demandait à eux de perpétrer
ce mensonge
vous savez ça vous ça vous donne des
frissons et je j'associe ses vétérans
aux malheurs des polynésiens ci est une
donnée est ressorti sur les 6000
employés à l'époque un les militaires
2000 aurait aujourd'hui des maladies
radio-induites alors un premier rapport
a tenté de minorer ses chiffres mais
peut-être que vous allez me me l'ait
confirmée donc finalement tout le monde
est touché bien écoutez il ya eu ou à
minima six essais sur les 46 essais
aériens qui ont arrosé
l'ensemble de la polynésie vous avez
celui qui est le plus documenté qui est
donc qui s'est passé le 17 juillet 1974
et qui a finalement exposé l'ensemble de
tous ceux qui étaient présents polynésie
à des doses bien au delà des 10
millisieverts
et donc tout ceci concourt aujourd'hui à
dire que le nombre de cas est fortement
fortement sous-estimé alors à l'époque
les polynésiens quand même au bout d'un
moment se sont mobilisés et puis
aujourd'hui continue à le faire et les
des manifestations il y à peu et ils
sont également suivis par gaston flosse
qui à l'époque était pro essais
nucléaires ou ça on est aujourd'hui la
contestation
écoutez je crois qu'aujourd'hui grâce au
combat du tavini huiraatira et de son
président monsieur oscar temaru qui
pendant des années a été le seul homme
politique à se lever face aux essais
nucléaires je crois qu'aujourd'hui à une
quand même une prise de conscience dans
la classe politique polynésienne et
personne aujourd'hui ne peut dire ne
maintient plus est cette thèse des
essais propre maintenant il y a toujours
des différences de positionnement
puisque vous avez d'un côté les
partisans de la présence française en
polynésie dont le principal souci est de
rester dans les bonnes grâces de macron
et puis vous avez de l'autre côté ceux
qui se battent pour que justice soit
faite et donc vous êtes parmi eux que
demandez vous parce que vous ont parlé
de la loi morin tout à l'heure qu'il ne
prend pas en compte tout un tas de
paradigme à savoir également les ayants
droit des victimes également le volet
environnemental et ça a été retoqué
comment on peut l'expliquer je ne me
l'expliqué toujours pas je sais d'autant
plus douloureux que vous savez en
coulisses
et en dehors de l'hémicycle la plupart
de mes collègues qui sont dans la
majorité qui étaient présents ce jour là
dans l'hémicycle me disait tu as
proposition de loi elle est pertinente
et elle est légitime et c'est cela même
qu'on retrouve dans l'hémicycle qui
votre compte
donc là je pense qu'il ya simplement une
logique politicienne
il ya des consignes de groupes qui ont
été données à cette à ses députés de la
majorité et il y a une forme de je ne
sais pas s'il faut dire de la naïveté ou
du cynisme à à croire que ce sont deux
jours d'une soi-disant table ronde de
haut niveau qui vont pouvoir remplacer
un travail de fond qui a été fait sur
deux années je vous remercie et métal
bois personnes n'ont pas marqué une
courte pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
le député mauve taille brotherson de la
3e circonscription de polynésie alors
monsieur brotherson les les doses reçues
par le corps parce qu'évidemment la
population a été très exposé à ces doses
le cea le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique a fait des calculs mais
disclose la fameuse enquête a déterminé
que les deux étaient bien plus forte est
ce que le cea tenté de minorer les
résultats pour moi ça relève de
l'évidence vous savez pendant des années
il faut voir déjà comment ont été faites
les mesures et ensuite il faut voir quel
était le l'objet réel de ces mesures
celles qui ont été retenues interpréter
et qui ont fait l'objet de calculs
n'avait d'autre but que de finalement
venir corroborer la thèse des essais
propres aujourd'hui on a pu avoir accès
à des archives qui était close à
l'époque les scientifiques de princeton
qui ont refait les calculs ont bien mis
en évidence avec une méthodologie
imparable que toutes ces estimations du
cea avait été minoré que les doses
étaient en réalité de deux à dix fois
supérieur de manière quasi systématique
et je ne vous parle pas vous savez
aujourd'hui il ya soit disant un suivi
des conséquences
alors vous avez des mesures qui sont
faites et à chaque fois ces mesures sont
publiés avec beaucoup de condescendance
en nous disons mais vous voyez bien
qu'il n'ya plus rien sauf que ces
mesures ne correspondent pas au point
tirent elles sont effectuées
si vous superposer la carte des mesures
et la carte des points de tir il n'y a
pas de correspondance donc en gros on ne
va pas mesurer là où se sont déroulés
lettier le mensonge continue
il ya tout de même une indemnisation le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas assez de
personnes indemnisées vous parliez de
120000 personnes exposées de maladie
extrêmement grave
il y a eu seulement une cinquantaine de
personnes indemnisées par le civ n
l'organisme dédié comment se fait-il
bien il ya plusieurs facteurs à ça vous
savez pour le
grand nombre de polynésiens ses essais
nucléaires c'est une
c'est une blessure qui est encore le
vivante dans toutes les familles
polynésiennes où vous avez quelqu'un qui
a perdu un oncle un père une mère
du fait de ces essais c'est un sujet
douloureux pour certains ils veulent
juste faire le deuil de tout ça et donc
ils ne vont même pas jusqu'à la
constitution d'un dossier parce que
c'est une histoire trop douloureuse pour
ceux qui franchissent le pas il faut
ensuite arriver à constituer le dossier
ce qui n'est pas une mince affaire c'est
un dossier administratif avec des pièces
à fournir quand vous venez des tuamotu
et que vous devez prendre l'avion faire
des heures de vol à chaque fois sur sur
treaty pour essayer de retrouver ces
pièces c'est tout sauf évident et
ensuite le critère d'élimination
principal et ça c'est le sival lui-même
qui le qui le dit c'est ce fameux
critères du millisievert qui a
finalement est venu remplacer le critère
du risque négligeable qui avait été
supprimé en 2010 est donc enfin 2018
l'état au travers d'un amendement
pourrait qualifier de cavaliers
législatifs puisqu'il n'est pas
introduit dans la loi morin mais dans la
loi de finances vient introduire ce
critère du millisievert qui aujourd'hui
est la cause majoritaire de rejet des
demandes d'indemnisation ce qui veut
dire que concrètement 80% des 2 c sont
éliminés comment on peut expliquer ce
chiffre mais je pense qu'il ya une
volonté à la fois de minimiser les
retombées des essais et puis aussi
finalement une espèce de réflexe
bassement je sais pas s'il faut dire
mercantile ou financiers qui est de ne
pas trop obérer le budget de l'état il
ya aussi une véritable opacité dans le
traitement de ces dossiers parce qu'on
cite l'exemple de deux soeurs qui ont
toutes les deux un cancer le même cancer
et l'une va être indemnisées pas l'autre
et puis il y à nombre de dossiers
confidentiels aussi qu'on arrive à
découvrir évidemment fil des enquêtes
pourquoi si trouble la question la
question est posée c'est à l'état d'y
répondre
vous savez moi j'ai reçu avant de venir
à paris dans mon cabinet a faim une dame
qui était atteinte non pas d'une mais de
trois pathologies qui sont toutes les
trois sur la liste des pathologies
radio-induites elle a un cancer de la
thyroïde un cancer du sein est un cancer
de l'estomac
oui c'est pas des petites grippe cette
dame était bien elle est née aux tuamotu
elle est née dans l'atoll de hao qui a
servi de base arrière aux essais
nucléaires et elle a passé toute son
enfance pendant les essais aériens haras
et bien son dossier a été refusé
sur quelle base sur la base du
millisievert cet argument du
millisievert
c'est un argument qui est irrecevable
puisque comme on disait en début
d'émission au moins lors d'un essai
l'essai centaure qui a eu lieu le 17
juillet 1974
l'ensemble de la population polynésienne
a été exposé bien au delà de ce
millisieverts donc pour nous c'est un
c'est un critère qui doit absolument
être retirés de la loi morin ce que bien
sûr l'état refusé au terme de ces deux
jours de de mascarade de bas niveau qui
le veulent appeler table ronde de haut
niveau l'art est évidemment il ya
également les dépenses pour la polynésie
caisse de prévoyance sociale en
polynésie a déjà dépensé 770 millions
d'euros pour ces maladies radio-induites
depuis 1985 et évidemment elle demande
le remboursement à l'état français ce
qu'il ya des démarches dans ce sens il y
a eu plusieurs démarches de la part de
la cps elle-même qui ont finalement reçu
une fin de non recevoir de la part du
conseil d'état qui a estimé que l'état
ne pouvait pas être tenu responsable
ou alors un responsable mais pas
coupable c'est un grand classique que
dans l'histoire de france dans
l'histoire de l'état français en tout
cas et vous avez eu également des
démarches à la fois des parlementaires
vous avez eu des démarches de l'exécutif
local
mais à chaque fois une fin de
non-recevoir là encore dernièrement ce
qui a été annoncé à la table ronde
enfin à l'issue de la table ronde c'est
une réflexion sur un éventuel une
éventuelle prise en charge pour les
futurs indemniser des dépenses de la cps
mais c'est trop mais cela n'engage que
ceux qui y croient en moi je n'y crois
pas du tout puisqu'il faut que ça se
traduise de manière concrète dans la
prochaine loi de finances et pour
l'instant je n'ai rien vu dans ce sens
vous n'avez pas très optimiste en tout
cas de cette réunion est ce qu'il est
ressorti un peu quelque chose notamment
sur la manière de de recueillir des
éléments sur place comment font les
polynésiens qui veulent déposer un
dossier où peuvent-ils s'adresser alors
c'est peut-être le seul élément
on va dire positif de cette table ronde
c'est ce sont des éléments
d'organisation avec là encore la
promesse de l'état de mettre sur place
des guichets des guichets multiples
dentiste qui permettront à plus de
personnes de venir déposer et constituer
leur dossier
on va voir comment ça se traduit de
manière concrète
vous savez ce qui est ce qui est
troublant dans tout cela c'est que
l'état est juge et partie et cela même
le ministère qui a finalement conduit
les essais nucléaires le ministère des
armées et le ministère en charge du
dossier donc comprenez que ça
s'entretient un climat de défiance à
tout le moins des polynésiens vis-à-vis
de l'action de l'état
je pense que ce serait déjà mieux que ce
dossier soit confié à un autre ministère
aps le ministère des armées
ce serait moins partial alors si on
parle des ministères le ministre de
l'outre-mer sébastien lecornu a dit
qu'il souhaitait assumer mais en de la
même manière il n'y a pas de pardon
alors comment on peut assumer sans a
demandé pardon est ce que tout ça n'est
pas un peu contradictoire
bien entendu et c'est là tout le tout le
paradoxe finalement de la position de
l'état
vous savez d'autres pays ont conduit des
essais nucléaires est quasiment tous en
déposer une demande de pardon envers les
peuples qui ont subi ces essais la
france aujourd'hui est quasiment le seul
état va seule puissance nucléaire qui ne
l'a pas fait pour le pays des droits de
l'homme je trouve que ça fait tâche
alors le 2 octobre 2018 une plainte a
été déposée devant la cour pénale
internationale contre la france pour
crimes contre l'humanité en raison
évidemment des essais nucléaires en
polynésie où en est cette plainte mais
écoutez cette cette démarche initiale
dont qui est à porter au crédit des
cartes et marroux va être rejointe dans
les jours qui viennent dans les semaines
qui viennent par des plaintes
individuelles de victimes donc qui
viendront à ce moment-là consolider le
dossier maintenant nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas dupes ce sont des
sondés dossier
comment dire de long terme ce sont des
dossiers qui vont être traités avec
beaucoup de précaution puisque les
enjeux diplomatiques sont sont énormes
mais pour nous en 2018 il s'agissait de
marquer le coup et de rappeler l'état
français à ses responsabilités vous
militez pour l'indépendance de la
polynésie on l'aura compris dans cet
entretien on vous doit notamment le fait
que la polynésie désormais soit inscrite
sur la liste de l'onu des pays à
décoloniser
quels sont les rapports économiques
aujourd'hui entre la polynésie et la
france et que voyez vous de l'avenir de
cette demande de cette liste alors vous
savez d'abord il s'agit d'une d'une
réinscription pas d'une inscription et
c'est l'histoire des essais nucléaires
nous étions inscrits sur la liste
initiale dès 1945 et nous avons été
retirés figurez-vous en 1963 quelques
mois avant le démarrage du cep chez nous
simple coïncidence
je ne sais pas l'histoire nous le dira
maintenant ce qui moi me frappe c'est
que avant l'installation du cep et avant
les essais nucléaires
la polynésie avait une balance du
commerce extérieur qui était
excédentaire nous exportions vers la
californie vers l'australie vers toute
la région qui nous environne est
aujourd'hui
donc quarante ans après les essais
nucléaires nous importons 90 % de ce qui
est consommé en polynésie d'aucuns
appellent ça le progrès moi j'appelle ça
simplement augmenter la dépendance pour
s'assurer que nous restions dans le
giron de l'état français et donc vous
voyez l'avenir comment parce que
emmanuel macron va faire cette visite en
polynésie le 25 juillet vous parlais
tout à l'heure de promesses qui
dresseront des promesses et qui sont
peut-être pas tenus mais ce que vous
pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir une
mobilisation supplémentaire des
polynésiens ont peut-être une prise de
conscience à l'assemblée déjà pour que
les lois que vous vouliez portée et bien
puisse être votée bien il y à il y aura
de toute façon déjà une grande marche
qui est organisée le 17 juillet donc
quelques jours avant l'arrivée prévue de
macron donc pour commémorer l'essai
centaure savait que donc donc je vous
cite et tantôt cette marche devrait
réunir plusieurs milliers de personnes
tout comme la cérémonie du 2 juillet
donc pour commémorer le premier tir
aldebaran du 2 juillet 1966 a réuni près
de dix mille personnes en polynésie
donc je pense qu'il y a il ya une prise
de conscience ou pour certains une
reprise de conscience de la population
polynésienne et je forme le voeu que le
président m'a camp ne viennent pas juste
faire une opération de com parce que
s'il commet cette erreur eh bien je
pense qu'ils vont dire il laissera une
tache indélébile sur son bilan
je remercie beaucoup ma taille brothers
ne nous avoir parlé des conséquences de
ces essais nucléaires français
évidemment des attentes des polynésiens
aujourd'hui je rappelle que vous êtes
député de la polynésie française et que
vous vous battez pour une réparation
sanitaires et environnementales je vous
remercie de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en intégralité
sur rtl france point tva bientôt sur
arte france
[Musique]